翻訳: Midori Imai
校正: Hiroko Kawano
「暮らし上手は幸せ上手」
これは 私達株式会社クラッシーの
30周年記念誌のタイトルです
皆さん 暮らしの価値っていうことを
改めてお考えになったことはおありですか？
心の満腹感を与えてくれるお袋の味
掃除の行き届いた清潔な空間で
疲れた心と身体を委ねるひと時
カーテンから漏れる心地よい朝の日差し
壁には
家族や友人と旅行した時の
記念写真の数々
この風景達が
暮らしの素敵ですよね
やさしい時間と空間
そして それを共有する
家族や友人という仲間が集う場
その場こそが生きる力を育み
あるいは 再生する暮らしの場
すなわち家庭です
暮らしあってこその仕事
暮らしあってこその人生
「まずは足元の暮らしを整えなさい」
私は母にそう教えられて育ちました
「家庭は 家族の心の写真
家庭こそが 家族の幸せの製造工場」だと
そんな普通の幸せを
意識している暇などない
仕事こそ価値
滅私奉公、画一、大量生産
大量消費、大量廃棄
20世紀の工業化社会
時代は規模の経済に向けて
ひた走ってきました
その途中で
私達が置き忘れてきてしまった生活価値
暮らしの素敵を
もう一度 見直してみませんか？
そうすると 心にゆとりが再来して
いい仕事をするためには
いい暮らしが必要なんだと一息つけます
次の時代にやわらかな社会をつなぐため
手を伸ばせば助けてくれる 支えてくれる
生活支援サービスインフラがある街づくり
このビジョンのもと 1986年
今から30年前
奇しくも 男女雇用機会均等法施行の年に
私 植田貴世子は 起業いたしました
工業化社会の経済武者達はこぞって
「女性の起業？保育？家事？介護だって？！」
妻がやったら タダの
そのアンペイドワークを
ペイドワークにする？
冗談じゃない！
「非常識極まりないことだ」と 一蹴します
まさしく 逆風突風吹き荒れる
厳しい船出でした
信念と 執念が
そして時代の歩みが
私を支え その背中を押してくれました
私自身は 女性として
暮らしの価値を唱える者として
既存社会の経済常識とやらとの
違いを恐れない勇気を持って
そして社会には
その違いを否定しない勇気を期待して
突き進んで 30年
ようやくですが 徳島に本社を置き
東、名、阪の40箇所のサービス拠点から
生活総合支援サービス事業を展開しています
株式会社クラッシーは社会企業
ソーシャルビジネス
時代の要請として生まれ、育ち
新たな公、「おおやけ」として
社会のために働く企業だと
自負しています
家庭が 家族の心の写真なら
地域は そこに住まう暮らし人の心の写真
その街 その街に合った
画一ならぬ多様なサービスを
提供することを心がけています
今 時代は
加速する少子高齢化
それに伴う 生産年齢人口の減少
進む核家族化という
大きい課題を抱えています
私の関心は
その課題により起こる現象
すなわち 家庭力の低下に
フォーカスしています
世帯人数 現在は2.49 人という
この現実が求めるものは
「主フ力」です
ちなみに 「主フ」の「フ」が
漢字ではなくカタカナです
これは男女いずれが担うにしても
家庭を運営する力を
「主フ力」と
私達がとらえているからですので
どうぞそのように ご理解ください
その主フ力はマルチタスク
365日 繰り返し繰り返し
家族のために注がれる
家族愛という心の力です
その主フ力が …
つまり生活支援サービスが
人々の暮らしを紡ぐために
どんなお手伝いをしているか
ここで 少し事例を通して
ご説明を致します
例えば 子育て層
彼らはとにかく時間不足です
朝は 自分の身支度に
子供の身支度とお弁当作り
お洗濯をしながら
夕食の段取りをしながら
もう戦争です
息つく暇なく １日を過ごす中で
ふと
子供の目を見て話をしていない自分に
気が付きます
子供と向き合うためだけの時間が
せめて週に１度でもあればと
お掃除やお洗濯は
家事サービスを活用することでしのぎ
ひととき 子供の話に
心の耳を傾けます
中高年層といえば
心のゆとり不足
孫も見てやりたい
でも親の介護も心と気持ちを求められます
とはいえ 地域社会や会社で
担う役割もあり
なにしろ 代わりがいない
出口のない こういった
困り事を抱えるのがこの世代
年末の大掃除や 親の病院の付き添い
そして 日常のお買い物など
なにかと少しずつ
家事サービスの助けを借りることで
心にゆとりを 暮らしに笑顔を
取り戻そうとします
そして高齢者層
押し寄せる加齢に抗いながらも
年々 気力体力の衰えは避けられません
お風呂のお掃除、窓拭き、お庭のお掃除
特に大きい家事 重い家事ほど
大変だと感じます
だけど 暮らしの場は整えておかないと
せめて 身の回りのことは
自分で賄わないと
ただでさえ忙しい子供達に
心配をかけてしまう
と 家事サービスを利用することで
不足を補います
日常の喧騒の中
人がしばし錨をおろす港 —
家庭
ここで 明日への活力が
醸成されます
何気ない１日が
豊かなる日常なんだと
暮らしの価値を
大切に思うからこそ
生活支援サービスがある暮らしが
スタンダードとなるべき
次の時代にやわらかな社会をつなぐため
私は世の中にそんな
新たな常識を作りたいと思うのです
そのためにも これまで
家族愛をそのエネルギー源として
自分の家族に向けて
発揮してきた主フ力を
この後は 人間愛に根ざす職業として
家庭力が低下した地域 街に向け 発揮する
まさしく 主フ力の社会化が必要であると
私は考えています
いかがでしょう 皆さん
ご共感頂けますでしょうか？
まず 暮らしを科学する
家事を細分化し 分類し 分析する
そして 可能な限り
ベースとなる家事行為を
平準化し
額に汗するだけじゃなくて
心に汗することができるような
サービス環境を担保する
業界を創り
誰もが安心して 同じ条件で
サービスを受けられるよう
サービス基準を定める
さらに 業界の活性化とともに
異業種の参入を促し 産業化を図る
そして この業界に
優秀な人材を獲得する
皆さん これが急務なんです
だって 学生の皆さんが
就活を始めるに当たり
「よし 生活支援サービス業界に
就職しよう」って
思い立つ若者に 出会ったことおありですか？
おそらく ありませんよね？
そんな業界があるという
認識がないからなんです
だから 産業化が必要なんです
家庭とは 最もプライベートな空間です
いかに ひとりひとりのお客様の
家風や価値観や日々の暮らしぶりに
お客様が 違和感を感じられないように
そっと寄り添い
柔軟に 巧みに 変化対応していくか
普通に考えると 非効率そのもの
しかも 相当に
高次な心の技を求められます
この 新しい概念のサービスを
どう創るか どう維持するか
そして どう届けるか？
生活支援サービス
これ 無形のサービス 形がないんですね
そうなんですが これに従来あるような
製品化・商品化と
継続安定供給の仕組みとマーケティングと
そういったビジネスのプロセスを
新たな視点と手法と知識と知恵と
たゆまぬ努力で
構築していかねばなりません
この 暮らしを科学するという
取り組みが進むにつれて
主フ力の職業化・社会化という
時代の要請に応えていくことができるのです
暮らし上手は幸せ上手
主フ力は家族愛、人間愛の代名詞
私はそれを母の背中から
そして母の生き様から学びました
今この時 生活価値
暮らしのすてき（価値）に
どうぞ思いを馳せて下さい
次の時代にやわらかな社会をつなぐため
妻がいつまでこうして元気で甲斐甲斐しく
台所に立っていてくれるんだろうと
言いしれない不安に さいまれる日々が
皆様の近未来の暮らしの姿とならぬよう
暮らしを科学し
主フ力の職業化・社会化
そして 暮らしサービスの産業化を
急ぎたいと念じています
皆様
皆様のご関心を
私達にどうぞお寄せ下さい
そして そのお力を お貸しください
私達 小さなクラッシーの
大きな挑戦は
これからも続きます
ありがとうございました
（拍手）